The joe rogan experience.
Very optimistic.
Speaking ignorance.
Can I show you this?
What is it?
What is this?
What?
Explain what we're watching.
I'm not really sure.
It's some sort of patriotic musical.
It's called,
that's America to me.
Look it up on Youtube.
Okay,
so
can you see it?
Okay?
Yeah.
Mom and dad and Apple Pie.
Baseball Games and pig Nixon is a real
go see this guy by work demands
sing the song looks like Don Frye.
Fuck the kid with Down's syndrome.
Eh?
Oh my goodness.
I want to talk to that
dude about the universe.
Wow.
Oh,
just to help her fellow man.
Not afraid to give her all,
oh my God.
That through karate kicks this.
This is the most insane thing
I've ever seen in my life.
These people for the iTunes folks,
I'm very sorry.
These people wearing the stars and stripes
shirts and they're standing in front
of a big stars and
stripes thing that says,
America,
this is straight and Saturday.
It's insane.
I've never seen anything like it.
These people probably can't
wait for this song to answer.
They can just go fuck each other.
I bet they just snort math and fuck the
shit out of each other and then they get
mad.
They're so repressed.
Oh Jesus.
I can't believe I did that.
Jesus.
Why?
We'll have the devil tell me,
well,
this is the last time is the last time.
And then they just meet in the same thing.
You just get brain surgery.
It's like at each other.
Pregnant should should modes
in each other make new retards.
This is all what we were talking about,
man.
This should happen to the Greeks who
have it to the Romans and having to
everybody.
Eventually the fucking tribe gets watered
down to the point where there's so
many of these fuckheads that people want
to pay attention to them and even want
to elect one of their own to
be the queen of the world.
You know,
people like that.
Look at it.
Look at the size of that audience,
man.
There were thousands
of people as last time.
You had a thousand people
for your fucking show.
It's been a long time.
Exactly.
It's ridiculous,
man.
You need to work that church angle shit.